the refugees stuck in idomeni at the
border between Greece and Macedonia feel
more desperate every day the Train way
then maybe it will be like a pressure we
are here we are living people here so
please open the burger but it's happened
before and it doesn't work Baha is
Syrian unlike everyone else here
he has already been granted asylum in
Germany he's come back here to pick up
his children and his wife Lena they
followed his flight from Syria later but
this border is as far as they got he had
to come because he what we need help
he's really good at English so he's
helping us a lot and he have he actually
have to go because the three weeks and
if you don't go he can't go back to
Germany so I hope we see him in Germany
more than 10,000 people are holding out
here in need Oh mani they're living in
small tents pitched under the open sky
although the Greek government has
promised to build them housing Baha says
the worst of it is the night so the
night it's a degrees average zero child
children here and it's the distant or
the no eating start crying because of
the cold and months stop crying
all of them sell its you can't you can't
sleep while all these children are
crying behind beside you the next
morning Baha and his wife Lena set off
for nearby Thessaloniki if he can't take
his family to Germany Baja wants to find
an apartment for them here in Greece
they visit a real estate agency in the
center of the city but their talk with
the agent lasts only a few minutes we
have a lot but not for one month for six
months so we left
but Baja and Lena don't want to give up
so they try another agent
ten minutes later the agent shows the
Syrian couple and apartment
she's asking 500 euros a month in rent
they say they can pay 250 a month but
that's too little for such a large
apartment it looks like there's no
chance but negotiations continue outside
Baja increases is offered by 50 euros
it's still less than the agent once but
she agrees to it there's a shelter and
wonderful it's better than staying in a
tent with nowhere yeah back to
civilisation again they're back in the
refugee camp for the first time in weeks
Baja and his family can't forget their
worries if only for a moment I don't I
don't want to think in the day that I
have to say to them go to buy again yeah
that's I don't want to think about it No
this is the last night for now that baha
Elina and their two children will have
to sleep on the ground Baja has to
return to Germany soon he doesn't know
when or where he'll see his family again